so uh we all love jokes and here at the
show we've been talking a lot about
different jokes and not just telling
them but talking about them okay listen
I think there are some jokes that are
overdone and need to get out of here
like forever so we're doing a bit called
joke retirement
all right so here's a joke that I think
needs to go
oh
crap it won't scan
oh no must be free
oh you don't know how much it costs I
will wait your a guess
free
is it free give it to me for free
uh
to that joke shut your mouth the joke is
over the cashier every cashier here is
it a thousand times a day stop it it's
not free if you're making that joke
you're free you're worthless be quiet
must be free is retired retired and I
know I know what you're thinking but
Pete what am I supposed to say next time
I'm at the store and something won't
scan I have an idea
anything else
literally anything would be better than
must be free for example
crap it won't scan
my why
I know it doesn't make sense but at
least it's funny